potes à bord et botanique ou d'un truc
batterie et la voilà enfin on le fait
maintenant regarde moi mérite fillon
prend le super regarde ça au regard de
sa com c'est peu au regard comme c'est
beau c'est super beau ça au contraire se
braque on regarde pas ça c'est pas beau
ce baladin tient debout le vert
je me contente je veux cependant pas en
avoir on a beaucoup dit m berrebi noir à
la montagne est belle la droite [ __ ]
pour la la qu'est ce qu'elle est belle
cette montagne c'est un rigolo tout cela
nous renvoie les verts à droite arabe
enfin de brands hatch à cause de vent
beau ok go to the breaks thérapie peu de
temps peut-être
tours ce magnifique espace voeux à la
presse du jeu et cette neige dès que le
plan dans le vert
et toi c'est pas les hater avec un maxi
l'avant n'avoir pas dormi dans la
voiture et au pardon dennis ladd
histoire est belle votre plaisir des
sens bien avant 20 heures les vagues y
compris le cadre comme un cow-boy ou
dire est que cela devant qui sont encore
beaucoup beaucoup plus pour passe
mais tout va boire devant la menace une
autre c'est marrant c'est exactement ce
que j'ai fait quelques années et marans
tellement to the world
en tout 20 tués à ce temps - to your
life is good shoping un seul geste y
goûte rien à voir il ya un truc tu
continues comme ça tu vas tomber j'ai
pas tué je suis blanc voila voila temps
devant ian paice de truc rond voila
voila tu étais en pétant le passé cela
voilà voilà
il a souffert un peu là dedans attend
the past is it c'est dessus il est apte
à gauche de sa mère l'était pas de suite
en attendant grandit plus est en toi tu
vois regarde pas les lois c'est ça qu'il
soit là voilà que la justice plutôt que
tout est ok c'est magnifique magnifique
guerre puisque tu vas sont là un peu à
droite encore pleine des 50 u20 droite
de saint sylvestre an plus tôt
pas pour
vente au détail de de peu d'un v8 en
avoir dix mois enfin détail de trucs way
to go to devra vaincre fait bien le tu
peux retourner vers la valette voit la
balle est à leur a parlé jeudi à bourg
murat d'une école d'art a fini elle sait
bien qu'ils montrent pas qu'ils
élargissent que vous avez avoir un peu
comme c'est beau après quoi la base
qu'est ce que c'est beau c'est [ __ ]
après pose de change laquelle répond
bien là dessus de 3 points à 30
non je suis en voilà fait un peu d'eux
élargi toi un peu s'en lavent le truc
est passé pas très très cher aux anglais
vachement valaudia fait vachement girl
je coupe changer qu'à toi regarde quand
tu montes à droite toit de sa voix là ça
vachement beau ça voilà voilà